foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar pathogen
detection and surveillance using
real-time PCR technology inside and
outside the lab
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by ubiquitom
to learn more visit ubiquitumbio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you're having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Eddie tan who is a senior scientist from
ubiquitum limited a mobile real-time PCR
machine manufacturer in New Zealand
for a complete biography of today's
speaker click on their name in the
presenters window at the top right of
your screen
Dr Eddie tan you may now begin your
presentation
hello
thanks for joining and Welcome to our
webinar my name is Eddie a senior
scientist from
I've been working with the team to
expand the applications of real-time
Pizza technology to work fast and
accurate Multiplex biomarker detections
across diverse areas of Interest
we are a mobile real-time Pizza Machine
manufacturer based in New Zealand
Although our company was established in
the year 2014 and yet we have been
working on mobile Pizza system
development for more than 15 years
The Innovation spread from the an
interplay of creative individuals with
teams from otago University and was
initially released as a full well mobile
real-time Pizza device namely freedom 4.
then the liberty stains features with an
easily handheld battery power device
that can test and realize sample data
via an iPhone x on top of it
the upcoming Liberty 16 Pro is now
Advanced with multiple channels and a
faster Ram rate
both Liberty 16 and pro have been
approved to be used alongside with FDA
us larva direct assays testing for the
Sask with two viruses
in this webinar we will be sharing the
latest trends and Innovations in PCR
technology and exploring the latest
breakthroughs in its field applications
and more
our goal is to provide you with an
in-depth understanding of the potential
of real-time piece of technology and how
it can be leveraged to address some of
the most pressing challenge facing today
whether you are a student researcher
entrepreneur or simply curious about the
field we hope that you will find this
webinar informative and
thought-provoking
to begin with
polymerase chain reactions abbreviated
as PCR is a laboratory techniques for
rapidly producing Millions to billions
of copies of a specific segment of DNA
it involved using short synthetic DNA
fragments called primers to select a
segment of a genome to be Amplified and
then multiple rounds of DNA synthesis to
amplify that segment
the development of real-time Pizza
technology begins in the 1990s
when scientists begin exploring ways to
monitor the amplifications of DNA
sequences in real time
here is an example of the most commonly
used type 1 probe acids which is labeled
with reporter and quencher dies that
emit at different wavelengths the prop
sequence is intended to hybridize
specifically in DNA Target regions of
interest between the two PCL primers
during polymerizations DNA strength
synthesis will begin the displace any
probes that have hybridized to the
Target sequence
when the reported eye molecule is
released from the probe and is no longer
near to click Ranger it can begin to
fluence
this technique enables researchers to
detect and measure the amount of DNA
being Amplified during PCR in real time
it is an advanced version of the
traditional PCR method and provides more
accurate and sensitive result in a short
time frame
and of course another critical
development was the creations of
specialized instruments called real-time
Pizza machines which can precisely
control the temperatures and conditions
required for Pisa as simultaneously
monitor the fluorescent signals emitted
by the dice during applications
real-time Pizza has since become a
wildly used technique in many areas of
biological research including genomics
Gene Expressions analysis Diagnostics
and forensics
its high sensitivities best necessities
and speed making an essential tool for a
world range of applications including
detecting infectious diseases
identifying genetic mutations and
monitoring Gene expressions in cells or
tissues
increase the usage of real-time PCR has
translated into scientific Publications
this figure shows the number of
Publications in the mat line database
that contain the words real-time PCR Q
pizza or real-time polymerase chain
reactions in their abstracts and full
tags the impact of real-time Pizza
technology on scientific wages is likely
to be greater than these numbers imply
as they represent only a fractions of
the total number of studies that utilize
real-time Pizza in the methods
and this Through Time Pizza expands the
influence of pisa-based Innovations and
presents intriguing its directions for
the futures of biomedical science
especially molecular Diagnostics and
molecular physiology and life science
educations
due to its high sensitivity and
specificity PCR is used for initial
detections of genetic material and so
it's most useful for detections of
infectious microbial agents
this cultural independent methods
enables to identify microbes they are
difficult to be cultured and isolate
however
because detections of these Asians by
Pisa does not require having live
organisms and detection of their nuclear
acid Footprints only give clues of their
assistance in the horse
it is not able to tell whether the
Infectious agents is alive or not as the
PCR diagnostic results are in capability
to distinguish between love and their
souls and thus result must be carefully
interpreted with disease symptoms for
subsequent for our patient care and
treatment
generally Pizza will give a result
within a few hours comparing to the
transitional culture-based methods that
normally takes days to complete
it can be used for various sample type
however dirty samples like faces soil
and Etc that contains various type of
estrogynous enzymatic proteins and heavy
metals which will inhibit the downstream
PCR reactions require additional care
while processing it and it's predating
of test result as false negative result
may appear as well
as said Real Time Pizza is widely
applied in biomedical and life science
and to be more specific it broadly
applies to Public Health microbiologies
that span the feels of human animal food
water and environmental microbiologies
with a focus on human health and disease
here we show some of the Publications
applying our Liberty 16 for pathogen
distractions including Sasuke V2
virus pprv and PPR like pathogens such
as foot and mouth disease viruses good
pork virus mycoplasma Capri pneumonia
African swine fever virus by fetal
bacterium species which is widely used
as an indicator of fecal pollutions in
water
so how will liberalistin it is when
comparing to the traditional lab-based
instruments
in this research article a parallel
testing of the Liberty 16 with life
cycle from roach dynastics for
detections and enumerations of two DNA
targets commonly used for studying water
contaminations was conduct
the authors conclude that the QPS of
performance of the Liberty 16s with both
known and unknown samples was comparable
to the benchtop life cycle
and other Publications from year schools
of Public Health
similar findings on the performance of
Liberty 16s have been reported
the Liberty 16 device yield a limit of
protections of 12 RNA copies per month
later comparable to the upper end of the
Audi range for the standard Slava direct
protocol when performing on larger rt2pr
instruments
here we show the list of instruments
that are compatible and could be used
for the FDA UA Salama direct assay
next to Kickstart with the real world
applicability let me brief you a little
bit background regarding the pandemic
crisis in New Zealand
we had the same situations just like
other most other countries Omicron and
lineage become dominant in New Zealand
in a relatively short period the rapidly
increasing cases had overwhelmed the
island and Jack accredited the
Diagnostic lab testing capacity and a
backlog of thousands of samples older
than five days had been
in this pandemic crisis several
companies proactive Federal of their
regular onsite covenanting surveillance
testing using our Liberty 16 device to
ensure workplace health and safety
don't play this industrial surveillance
testing is not replacing the official
Public Health testing indeed any
suspicious findings were subsequent
direct to an appropriate Diagnostic lab
for complementary results
the Liberty 16 has been clinically
validated as a flexible and accessible
device for running out of FDA UAE to our
direct assets for such Coupe 2
detections
we found that it was very much
Deployable for industrial settings of
private companies especially with low
resource settings to have a reliable
screening results in a timely manner
the benefits of direct saliva base rdq
Visa detections are as follows it reduce
risk of infections to the stuff
conducting the sampling since
self-harvesting is easy and then the
flower samples is stable at room
temperatures and it was at least 20 days
stable at four degree without viral
transport medium
apart of that no RNA extraction step is
needed and therefore decrease the
testing time and course and most
importantly
it provides height specificity and
sensitivity
that are comparable to a Nissan
pharyngeal swaps based detections
and in fact we reveal the count of all
non-negative results that were reported
by this company that apply limited
stains like a direct assay for their
on-site surveillance testing
they were able to pick up non-negative
results since February 2022 being in
agreement with the unconstrained Omicron
committee Community outbreak and yet
over the period from February to May
2022 a total number of 68 track case
were identified
this results were 400 concordant with
iron Jack diagnostic testing results
here we would like to show you some of
the testimonials from these
organizations
we have telecoms and apple growing
packing and exporting company that has
more than 300 employees and seasonal
workers to move 250 tons of apples daily
then the nippy Port which is an
international good trading port in New
Zealand
the balance of fertilizer manufacturing
Supply and sales company that also
provide advisory service which has more
than several hundred employees at a time
to maintain daily operations
and finally the white perilia an
Institute proactively help influence and
Advance the local Maori economy and
Social Development they not only use
this approach to keep their stuff safe
but also brought this testing to some
rural areas and help with the community
testing
to put a long story start these
organizations were able to manage their
essential supply chain provide a safe
working place for their stuff and
maintain the business run uninterruptly
in a daily basis
so what are all detections of covid-19
is important as you may have learned
early covid-19 detections and following
effective public promoting systems are
crucial for decision makers to respond
immediately and to the real-time
situations with strategies
the most important thing is to cut off
the transmission change in the same
functional or departmental groups of
people at workplace
it is not worthy that lost productivity
from the absence of several employees
due to sick leave can be significantly
less expensive than a possible downtime
from closings and office size the entire
plant or the Distribution Center because
of sick employees or from the inspecting
the site
next we would like to share with you
the works from Professor Hollywood
Bowers who has been using our machine in
support of routine harmful algae bloom
monitoring and monetary Municipal wealth
and Monterey Bay aquariums in California
these few efforts were used to develop
an initial pipelines for DNA attractions
towards a quick and dirty approach for
determining the presence of Target
species such as pseudo Niche and
dinofuses and Etc the process allowed
for Rapid reporting of results to the
aquarium which relies on the road sea
water for some exhibit to monitor for
the threat of the harmful algae blooms
events and assess the current
filtration's methodology
to mitigate potential impacts
and the works are still going on
next before we bring this presentation
to the end please allow me to introduce
our newest machine the Liberties improve
over the past two years the emergence of
Sasuke V2 has highlighted the need for a
rapid and accurate testing solutions to
successfully respond to a worldwide
pandemic and identify infected patients
to limit the pathogen spread
the new Liberty 16 crew is capable of
like multiplexings using most of the
common dyes for up to four Target
detections the machine is equipped with
blue and Amber LEDs for fluorescence and
citations and Gathering like green
yellow red and deep brake signals in the
corresponding Four Color channels
the common and compatible diets such as
Femme Wick
June Texas rate and sci-fi were shown
here
the machine is also Advanced with a
faster Ram rate double faster with with
shorter run time
for said the the celebrator thermal
protocol which needs 85 minutes on Libre
16 takes only like 55 minutes on the pro
and overall the living skin Pro
describes here aims to expand our
testing capacity permitting pathogen
detections with a multiplex acids and
increased speed while retaining the
Simplicity of use
the above figure shows the detection
range across four channels on the pro
ranging from more than 100 Millions to
10 copies per microliter of DNA using a
single Plex as is it shows good
linearities across these four channels
and all acids achieve pretty good
amplification efficiencies
furthermore we compare our Liberty steam
pro to a market leading traditional
lab-based competitor in instruments in
terms of detection sensitivity there is
no difference between these two machines
for detecting all Targets
and most recently the Liberty 16 pro has
also been validated for the fda's EOS
level Direct assays while comparing to
our previous model bb16 pro has the
lower LED and shorter runtime beneficial
for from its multiplexing capability the
testing capacity is increasing from more
than 200 percent
the attention video is just showing how
to set up and run an essays in this
compact battery power machine
foreign
specifications of Liberty 16 Pros
finally if you are looking forward to
applying the real-time Pizza technology
at your workplace for either research or
survey purposes please reach out to us
we very much love to hear from you and
are happy to explore this opportunity
together and hopefully we can provide
you with the better Solutions
essentially appreciate your your
attentions and if anyone would like more
information or has questions please feel
free to contact me at my ebook address
as shown above thank you
thank you Dr Eddie tan for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
as of now I'm not seeing any questions
however if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now by typing
them into the ask a question box and
click Send
I will give you all a moment to do so
foreign
great it looks like we do not have any
questions at this time uh but thank you
Dr Tan for your time today do you have
any final comments for our audience
no no exactly but uh to sum up here like
we are here just to share with you like
the inspiring stories like applying our
liberties things for the on-site uh
surveillance testing outside the lab so
it's uh so it just really depends on
your needs and then feel free to like
reach out to us and then if you have any
like problems regarding how to use these
machines on your hands so that's it
great thank you again Dr Eddie tan for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor ubiquitum for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
your interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye